[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat le
chômage en baisse pour le mois de
septembre - 1,8 pour cent de demandeurs
d'emploi en catégorie a au niveau
national la france passe donc sous la
barre des sous la barre symbolique des
trois millions et demi de chômeurs des
chiffres encourageants mais à nuancer
tout de même dans les yvelines on note
une baisse de 3% sur le même mois de
septembre mais que traduit ce chiffre où
en est-on du chômage dans le département
quelles solutions apporter pour lutter
contre le chômage de masse et engager un
retour à l'emploi durable le point sur
le chômage dans le département c'est
donc le débat du jour et en plateau ce
soir pauline luciani pinzelli directrice
thériault territoriale par donc délégué
des yvelines de pôle emploi et hervé de
marc directeur de l'école de la deuxième
chance à trappes
bonsoir à tous les deux bien venu alors
tout d'abord quel regard est ce que vous
portez chacun sur ce chiffre un cette
annonce moins 3 % de demandeurs d'emploi
dans les yvelines pour le mois de
septembre
est-ce que ça a du sens pour vous je me
tourne vers vous d'abord hervé de marque
c'est ce pour quoi on se bat l'école
fêter ses 10 ans et ce pour quoi on se
bat
quotidien donc oui ça a beaucoup de sens
et très bonne nouvelle est pour vous oui
c'est effectivement une bonne nouvelle
c'est on va dire c'est la suite d'une
tendance qu'on avait déjà observé depuis
le début de l'année alors d'abord il ya
effectivement un chiffre à rappeler
c'est que le chômage a baissé en fait
depuis le dernier trimestre 2016 il
était à 7 4% de les yvelines il est
passé à 7,1 pour cent à la fin du
premier trimestre 2010 est donc là on
est dans une continuité
bon ce qui est à noter c'est que et on
s'en réjouit
ça reste dans en ile de france le taux
de chômage le plus bas de la région
comparativement aux autres aux autres
départements la région et à 8,3 pour
cent et le national est à 9,7 pour cent
donc on est très heureux c'est vrai parc
en revanche que ça ça ne doit pas
masquer en fait des disparités dans les
dents les difficultés d'accès à l'emploi
qui continue à s'accentuer
c'est ce qu'on appelle un phénomène de
polarisation dans l'accès du marché du
travail qui fait qu' il ya des
catégories des populations de demandeurs
d'emploi qui ont de plus en plus de mal
à accéder au marché du travail alors
encore sur ces chiffres on observe si on
observe les chiffres donc sur trois mois
ou même un an les données changent et là
c'est peut-être un peu moins
encourageants +0 27% sur un an + virgule
0 3% sur les trois mois
comment est-ce qu'on doit donc
interpréter ces chiffres dans le
département alors ça reste effectivement
c'est une on va dire c'est un tassement
de la courbe du chômage mais ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas eu un recul
net de la catégorie à c'est-à-dire la
catégorie des demandeurs d'emploi
n'ayant pas du tout travaillé dans le
mois
donc on
on espère tous à l'inversion de la cour
en toile à dreux descente de la course
est vrai qu'elle est en train de de
s'aplanir et on attend et on espère sur
les mois qui viennent la décrue bon on
est assez confiant parce qu'il ya des il
ya des phénomènes lourd voilà qui nous
qui nous incite à penser
qu'effectivement ça y est on va y
arriver
bon d'abord il ya un retournement delà
de la conjoncture économique
ça fait déjà quelques mois que les
indicateurs tant que l'emploi
intérimaire laisser la baisse des
cessations d'activité sur le département
qui nous faisait dire que on a là un
début de reprise de croissance donc ce
qui est quand même une chose essentielle
et puis un deuxième un deuxième élément
c'est qu'effectivement on avait
travaillé en 2016 sur l'accompagnement
des parcours professionnels et en sur le
département des yvelines on a envoyé
plus de dix mille demandeurs d'emploi en
formation
et aujourd'hui on est en train de
bénéficier en fête des fruits de ce
travail puisque plus de 50 % des
demandeurs d'emploi reprennent un emploi
à l'issue de ces formations
on était à la fois sur des formations on
va dire de premier niveau donc notamment
sur l'illettrisme etc mais aussi des
formations qualifiantes et
professionnaliser ça commence à payer
ses fruits sur les formations n'y
reviendra un petit peu plus tard mais je
me tourne vers vous et hervé demain pour
sur le terrain comment est-ce que vous
voyez vous pouvez analyser ces chiffres
on a des chiffres des statistiques
parfois faladé donner un petit peu tiré
par les cheveux quand on plonge dans ce
dans ces dossiers comment est-ce que sur
le terrain vous au sens de votre école
école de la deuxième chance vous pouvez
analyser vous voyez ça comme le disait
madame aussi l'année c'est très
polarisée et en fait le métier de
l'école deuxième chance c'est
d'accueillir des jeunes qui entre 18 et
25 ans qui sont sortis du système
éducatif sans diplôme ni qualification
et nos écoles on en a trois dans le
département et on les a positionnés une
sur saint quentin en yvelines attrape
une autre aux mureaux et une autre à
mantes la ville et on est très en lien
avec les quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville
donc c'est à dire qu'on est avec des
jeunes qui de toute façon ce seront
probablement parmi les derniers en
termes de catégories à sentir le
bénéfice de ce regain d'emplois dans le
département donc très concrètement chez
nous ça ça se sont pas encore ou en tout
cas très très peu par contre dans la
construction des projets professionnels
dans la capacité à les concrétiser
effectivement on est plutôt sur une
année 2010 est qui a des bons résultats
après on a une petite difficulté en ce
moment c'est qu'on a du mal à recruter
des jeunes donc j'en profite
on a de la place dans les écoles de la
deuxième chance s'il ya des jeunes qui
sont concernés ce qui manquait ce qui
fait défaut qu'est ce que c'est
compliqué alors il ya peut-être ces
fameuses 10000 formation finalement ça
n'est pas du tout dans un univers
concurrentiel mais les gens ont plus de
choix
il ya peut-être d'autres arbitrages
qu'ils se sont faits et puis c'est pas
si facile que ça quand on est dans la
situation que j'ai décrite juste avant
de se dire moi j'ai 20 ans en moyenne
c'est leur âge et je vais allé
m'inscrire à l'école de la deuxième
chance c'est un vrai pari c'est quelque
chose d'engageant il faut aussi accepter
que la première chance elle a pas réussi
et c'est pas facile de l'admettre pas
des fois je le comprends bien et donc
tout ça ça crée un travail
d'accompagnement mais on est en
interaction avec les conseillers de pôle
emploi pour justement que les jeunes qui
ont besoin de notre école qui restent
qui répondent aux critères que j'ai
décrit tout à l'heure on puisse les
accompagner mais en moyenne on travaille
avec eux un peu plus de 6,7 mois
justement sur l'interaction comment est
ce que vous arrivez à harmoniser
concrètement les efforts de chacun pour
pour arriver à pousser les plus jeunes
qu'est-ce qu'on parle des jeunes à un
retour à l'emploi sur pôle emploi on a
on a depuis quelques années on a
beaucoup de dispositifs effectivement en
direction des jeunes
et d'ailleurs pas seulement dans pôle
emploi on peut citer donc chez nous
l'accompagnement intensive jeunes qui
coup sur le département des yvelines
concerne 700 jeunes qui s'adresse à des
à des jeunes inscrits à pôle emploi
c'était important donc des jeunes qui se
sont inscrits et qui au gré de but des
noces qui compose avec eux manifestent
des difficultés d'insertion et
d'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
de moins de moins de 26 ans très
exactement et ça peut aller jusqu'à 30
ans sur sur des zones des zones occupées
vais donc effectivement on ça a été ça a
été cet accompagnement intensif il a été
fait spécifiquement pour aider ces
jeunes dans leur insertion
professionnelle
on a aussi avec les missions locales la
garantie jeunes qui elles visent des
publics qui sont on va dire encore plus
en difficulté c'est à dire qu'ils
n'aiment hésite même à s'inscrire à pôle
emploi ce qui est effectivement je
rejoins monsieur sur le fait qu' on a un
vrai enjeu à travailler sur des publics
qui n'acceptent ne même pas où ça va ce
public de l'emploi c'est à dire que des
décrocheurs scolaires d'aider des jeunes
qui n'ont pas les clefs n'ont pas
confiance dans le système en fait pour
les portes et porté vers l'emploi
et puis qui n'en n'ont pas les premières
clé dans la formation et c'est vrai que
c'est là qu'est un dispositif comme
l'école de la deuxième chance est
vraiment intéressant mais on est on
s'aperçoit qu'on notamment dans des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville on a
des fragments comme cette population qui
échappe y compris à pôle emploi
donc c'est vrai que tout l'enjeu c'est
de travailler ensemble pour communiquer
sur les différents dispositifs qui
existent
voilà à pôle emploi en dehors de pôle
emploi pour construire un parcours parce
qu'effectivement l'ambition à l'école de
la deuxième chance ans c'est aussi de
porter aussi ces jeunes dans le dans le
système et dans l'est on va dire les
réconcilier aussi avec les dispositifs
d'accompagnement ultérieure parce que
aujourd'hui les parcours prochaine sont
de plus en plus long donc cesser il faut
pouvoir s'inscrire comme ça dans un dans
un pareil justement l'école de la
deuxième chance donc privilégie les
sorties vers la formation qualifiante et
vers l'alternance est ce que la
formation peut dire que c'est un peu
c'est la clé pour pour lutter contre le
chômage
vous êtes d'accord avec de marque
ensuite passé la parole nous on
individualise beaucoup tout ce qu'on
fait avec les jeunes qu'on accueille et
donc la formation cc c'est pas en
augmentation en ce moment des sorties
positives elles sont plutôt en
augmentation
par contre la formation les jeunes et
les jeunes qu'on accueille chez nous
c'est pas représentatif de l'ensemble de
la population
ils ont vraiment la volonté d'accéder à
un emploi et donc nous on va pas dire
qu'on privilégie la formation par contre
on vérifie avec eux que est-ce qu'il ne
leur sembleraient pas que ce serait la
meilleure solution pour eux et en
particulier les formations en alternance
parce que justement on garde ce lien
avec la partie professionnelle et c'est
ce qu'il est qui les accroche vraiment
au projet et donc quand on fait ce
travail là avec eux il ya une partie des
métiers par exemple si vous voulez être
cuisinier avec le
le titre ça n'existe qu'avec un diplôme
et au moins le ca paix est donc un jeune
dans le projet professionnel et d'être
cuisinier à un moment il faut qu'il
puisse rattraper la formation initiale
ou continue
peu importe mais mais par contre les
jeunes construisent leur projet
professionnel et y en a même qui
reviennent via des dispositifs comme la
valorisation des acquis de l'expérience
ou des choses comme ça qui reviennent
vers quelque chose de diplômes en mai
après avoir passé une période dans les
entreprises mais à l'école de la
deuxième chance
on passe la moitié du temps en stage en
entreprise pour construire un projet
professionnel concret et et en fait on
travaille sur cet élan là et qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la requalification
est ce que c'est aussi un autre moyen
encore de lutter contre le chômage est
ce que ça marche est ce que vous arrivez
le changement de calcul
oui de diriger vers une autre un autre
métier pour un demandeur d'emploi de
plusieurs mois années alors déjà un
chiffre 38 % des personnes inscrites à
pôle emploi qui reprennent un emploi le
prennent sur eux reprennent sur un
métier différent de celui qu'ils dont
ils ont exercé donc c'est sûr c'est
important et c'est d'ailleurs amené à
une tendance qui est amenée à
s'accroître en fait atteint dans les
années qui viennent si on analyse les
tendances lourdes du marché du travail
on s'aperçoit que pour plusieurs raisons
un actif va être amené à changer
j'allais pas dire si de plus en plus
souvent de métier et voir d'orientation
professionnelle donc oui la formation
c'est important le la réflexion sur
l'orientation professionnelle tout au
long de la vie et excès est
excessivement importante
eva eva va amener enfin nous amène nous
a pour l'emploi à travailler
différemment avec nos usagers 1 depuis
le lancement du conseil en évolution
professionnelle est de plus en plus on
travaille avec avec nos usagers sur la
projection professionnels sur plusieurs
années on a d'ailleurs à ce titre
intègre et des psychologues du travail
en agence locale qui travaille avec les
conseillers pour des cons des textes
avec notre demandeurs d'emploi une
problématique d'orientation ou la
volonté de jeudi je m'inscris à pôle
emploi et je pense que je ne pourrais
pas exercer le métier que j'exerçais
auparavant eh bien on met en place tout
de suite des outils pour les accompagner
parce qu'effectivement ça va être un
facteur clé de succès dans les années à
venir
cette capacité à pouvoir réfléchir sur
les compétences qu'on a acquise les
compétences qu'on peut mobiliser plus
tard et vis-à-vis des recruteurs
d'ailleurs c'est un travail aussi qu'on
engage parce que face à la pénurie de
candidats qui est souvent pointée en
fait sur le marché du travail bien la
réponse c'est comment on travaille sur
les compétences alors des jeunes des
moins jeunes aussi pour effectivement
adapté au marché du travail
ce sera le mot de la fin je suis navré
l'émission est plus à sa fin et la fin
de de 7,8 débat merci à tous les deux
est venu sur ce plateau pour cette
thématique ce soir un consacré à la
situation du chômage dans le département
des yvelines
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet et a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux twitter facebook
instagram vous les connaissez bonne
soirée à tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]